hi everyone
welcome to this live session by simply
learn today
we are going to talk about some of the
essential programming interview
questions for a data scientist role
now since python is widely used
programming language for data science
machine learning and deep learning
we will be solving our problems in the
python programming language using
jupyter notebook
so let's wait for a few minutes for
people to join in
also if you haven't subscribed to our
channel yet then please make sure to
subscribe to it now and stay updated
with all the recent trending
technologies
and if you want to get the code file
that we will use in this session
then please put your email id in the
chat section of the video
our team will share the interactive
ipython notebook with you
so let's begin with our first question
our first question is
how do you get a list of all the keys in
a dictionary
now in python for data science data
structures play an important role to
store and manipulate data
dictionary is one such data structure
that is declared using curly braces
and they are written as key value pairs
you can see on the screen
i have my dictionary called d and it is
assigned using curly braces
now to get a list of all the keys in a
dictionary we use
the dot keys function now let me take
you to my jupyter notebook
so here is my jupyter notebook and you
can see my first
cell i have my dictionary defined
so the name of the dictionary is d and
it has the key values the keys are the
country names and the values are
the capitals of each country so i have
india and the capital is new delhi
then i have usa the capital is
washington
similarly i have spain madrid and we
have
germany and berlin now india
usa france spain all these are my keys
so to get the keys i'll use the dot keys
function
so i'll write my dictionary name that is
d
dot i'll give keys
close the brackets and hit shift enter
you can see these are the list of my
keys
in the dictionary d all right
okay now let's move to our next question
so our next question is what do you mean
by list comprehension in python
so list comprehensions are a sort and
easy way to define and create
new lists based on existing lists
so suppose you want to iterate through a
list and find all the even numbers in
the list
you can either use a for loop and an if
condition as
shown here or you can write a list
comprehension to do it in one line of
code
you can see this is my list
comprehension
so let me show you both the ways
all right so here on my jupyter notebook
let me declare my list as
l equal to i'll pass in a few numbers
let's say 5 comma
12 10 we have 14
43 11
7 9 and let's see the last element in
the list is
6 all right let me run this
list ok now
let me create an empty list let's say
list1
and let this be an empty list with
square brackets
then i'll use the looping construct to
find the even elements in the list
so i'll write a for loop called for
item in my list l
i'll give colon then i'll give my
condition
f item
percentage 2 is equal to equal to 0
which means if the remainder is 0 then
i'll append the items
to my empty list which is list1 so i'll
write
list1 dot append
and i'll pass in the argument my item
now let me go ahead and
print my list i'll write print
the final list
using a for loop
i'll give colon give a comma
and pass in my new list name which is
list1
now let's run this you can see
using this for loop and the if condition
i have got
all the even elements in my list which
was
l you can see my original list and
12 10 14 and 6 where all the even
numbers present in my list
now this task you can do it using list
comprehensions as well
so let me show you how to do that so i
have my list
defined let me just copy this here i'll
paste it
and now i'll create another variable
which is
list 1 i'll write equal to
now here
using square brackets i'll write item
for item in
l and i'll give my if condition as if
item percentage 2
is equal to equal to 0
then i'll print my resultant list so
i'll write
print let's say
resultant list
using list comprehension
i'll give a colon then a comma and i'll
pass in my new list which is list one
so here whatever is there
in my square brackets is called the list
comprehension technique
let me just print this and i'll get the
same result
so these are my even numbers
all right so let's move to the third
question
so our third question is given a list of
numbers
find the squares of the numbers using
the map function in python
now the map function calls the specified
function for each element of an iterable
and returns a result
so let me show you an example to find
out squares of a list of numbers using
the map function
okay so let's first define a function
called
square so i'm using my def keyword and
i'll
pass in my user defined function name as
square
and i'll give my parameter as x
and i want to return
the square of x which is x
star x
all right and then let me define my
list of numbers so i'll
pass in a variable called num and let's
say i want to find the squares of
5 numbers 1 2 3 comma 4 comma
5. here
i'll pass in another variable which will
store the
resultant list so i'll write
num underscore squared
equal to here i'll use my map function
so map function takes in two parameters
first it will take in
the user defined function name which is
square here
and the list of numbers which is num
i'll run a for loop i'll write for let
me just scroll down
i'll write for num in
num underscore squared
print num
so this is my map function so
it will map all the elements in the list
to
this function which is square i'll just
print it
you can see we have the list of squares
from the num list which has the elements
one two three four and five now moving
ahead
coming to our fourth question
the fourth question is on to write a
program that will filter out the numbers
divisible by
3 from a tuple using the lambda
functions
so lambda functions are anonymous
functions that are not defined by the
def keyword
in python so here you can see i have the
example
so this is a tuple i have defined and
using filter along with the lambda
function i am trying to find out the
numbers that are divisible by
3 and finally i am printing those
numbers
so let's do it on our jupiter notebook
all right so we are on the jupyter
notebook
so first i'll define a tuple
let's say the variable name is my
underscore
dop which stands for my tuple and
using brackets i'll pass in my
double values let's say 5 12
10 18 we have 43
9 7 11
and let's say six so
you can see these are the numbers
present in my tuple now
i'll create another variable called
new tuple and i'll use my
tuple function and inside the tuple
function i'll use the filter function
that will filter out only the values
that are divisible by 3 and now i'll
write my lambda function
so notice this clearly how to use a
lambda function
i'll use the keyword lambda
and then i'll pass in a variable
x now this
should consider only those values
that are divisible by 3 so i'll write x
percentage 3
should be equal to equal to 0
and
i'll give my tuple
as the variable here all right now we
have declared our lambda function
let's just go ahead and print my new
tuple which is new underscore tup
so here you can see i have my tuple
function
inside the tuple function i'll use my
filter function that will filter only
those values divisible by 3
and to filter those values i have used
my lambda function here and passed in my
original tuple which is my tuple it's
actually my tup
so let's delete the last two letters
let's just go ahead and print this there
you go
you can see we have 12 18 9 and 6 are
the only numbers that are divisible by
3 from this tuple moving to the next
question
so our next question is how to create a
data frame from a dictionary
now to create a data frame from a
dictionary you can use the pandas
library and the dot
data frame function now pandas is a
popular library in python that is used
for data manipulation
so let me show you how you can create an
employee dictionary
and then convert that into a data frame
okay so here on my jupyter notebook let
me go ahead and import my pandas library
so i'll write import pandas as
pd and next
let's create my employee dictionary so
i'll write
emp which stands for employee and
and within curly braces i'll give my key
value pairs
so my first column would be the name of
the employee
and let's pass in a list of
employee names i'll write ami
let's say we have angela
third employee's name let's say we have
samuel
and let dany be our
fourth employee i'll give a comma
now the second attribute in our
dictionary will be the age of the
employee
so my key would be age and
let's create a list of age values
i'm assigning random values to those
employee
age 30 and let's say 32
and let's create another
variable called city
here variable refers to the column name
of the data frame let's say ami is from
new york
then we have angela from chicago
let's say samuel is from boston
and we have danny from let's say
seattle
okay so if i run this i have my
employee dictionary created so if you
want to see the dictionary you can write
print
and pass the variable name which is emp
here
so this is my dictionary now to convert
this dictionary into a data frame you
can simply write
df and you can give the pandas library
as pd and use the data frame function
so i'll write data frame
and i'll pass in my dictionary name
which is emp here
let's run it okay so we have
successfully created our data frame
now let me just print the data frame
i'll write df
there you go you can see i have a nice
table here which is actually a data
frame here
you can see the indices and you can see
our
column names as name age and city and
these are the
values or the rows all right
now let's see the sixth question we have
so the question is what is the
difference between
loc and iloc in python
now as data scientists you would often
want to analyze a chunk of data and not
all the rows in it so loc and iluc
functions can help you fetch specific
rows and columns from your data frame
loc function uses row or column labels
to select and slice data from a data
frame while iloc
uses integer index to select specific
rows and columns
remember iloc stands for index location
i'll use a card data frame to show how
loc and iloc works now
on your screens you can see the data
frame so it has
a column called brand which has
different brand names such as ford
this hyundai tata mahindra this maruti
the skya motors
then we have the year in which the car
was manufactured
we have the number of kilometers the car
has run
we have the city and the mileage the car
gives
so let me first create this data frame
on my jupyter notebook
okay so here on my notepad i have my
code written to create the data frame
that is car i'll just copy this code
and i'll paste it to this cell
okay let me just run it if i go on top
you can see we have successfully created
our
car data frame now let me go ahead and
print this data frame so i'll write
print in brackets i'll give my
data frame scar let me run it
all right so here is my data frame
now suppose you want to see the data
from second row
till the fifth row for brand and city
columns so
you can use the loc function so i want
my data from the second row
till the fifth row for brand and city
columns
so let me show you how to do that so
first i'll write
my data frame name that is car and then
i'll give my
function as loc and
within brackets i'll give my
row index values so i'll go from 2 to 5
which is second row to fifth row and
i'll give my column names as brand
you give a comma and my second column
which i want is
city so here i'm using the
labelled beast indexing let me just run
it
there you go you can see we have the
information available for
the second row third row fourth row and
the fifth row
all right similarly let's see one more
example for
index location based slicing
so suppose you want to see the data from
second
third and fourth row for year kilometers
and city columns
so for that you can use the iloc
function
so i want the value for second
third and fourth row and the columns
that i want
are years kilometers and the city column
so for that i'll give my data frame name
as
car dot this time i'll use iloc
and within square brackets i'll
give my row values and
the column values now
one thing you should notice here is
if you use iloc python
will exclude the last index which is the
fifth row and similarly here it will
exclude the
last index from the column which is the
fourth column
if i run this you get the desired result
now let's see another example
let's say this time i want to print the
rows that have mileage
less than 25 for brand and city columns
so you can use a print function
and i'll pass in my data frame as car
and use loc here
i'll give my condition as
car and i want my condition that is
mileage
should be less than 25
and i want
the brand name so i'll use a square
bracket
and give my brand column
and i also want the city column
okay let me
close it if you run this
now these are the brand names renault
tata and kia which have
mileage less than 25 let me just verify
this
you can see all these values are less
than
25
similarly you can use the iloc function
as well
i can write print i'll give car dot
iloc within square brackets
i'll give car
and my condition column is mileage
now this should be less than 25
i'll use dot values
and then i'll give my column numbers as
0 comma 2 let me run it
there you go the same result we have got
it
using iloc function this time
and you can see the columns were 0 comma
2 which means
we wanted the first column which is
brand
and the second column which was
kilometers
all right now moving to our seventh
question in the list of questions that
we have
the question is how is list dot append
different from list dot extend
now list dot append adds its arguments
as a single element to the end of the
list
the length of the list increases by 1
here
and list dot extend iterates over its
arguments and adds each element to the
list
the length of the list increases by the
number of elements in its arguments
so let me show you the difference
on my jupyter notebook okay so let's
create a list called list 1
equal to i'll create a list let's say it
has some country names like
india then we have
usa and i'll consider one more
country let's say canada
okay now let me print the length of this
list also
i'll use the length function for that
all right now
let me append one more list so i'll use
the append function
i'll write list one dot append
and within
brackets i'll give my new list which has
two more country names let's say france
and spain
okay and here let me print
list1 and let's also print the length of
the list
again i'll use the length function
and my list name which is list1
so just mark we are using append here
let me run this
there you go so here you can see
my original list had three elements
since the length is three
now when i appended this new list which
had two elements
france and spain are size increased by
one
and the length of the new list is four
now let me just
copy this code and
instead of append let me write extend
so that we can see the difference
between append and extend
i'll just scroll down run it
here you can see our original list had
three elements but after we extended our
list with two more elements the length
of the new list became
five so these are the five elements in
the list
and here you can see there were total
four elements in the list
when we appended the new list
okay now moving to our eighth question
suppose you have a car data set which
has a mileage column
you need to create a new field called
mlg
that will accept two values if mileage
is less than 25
then the value should be low mlg and if
the mileage is
greater than or equal to 25 then the
mileage should be
high mlg or the value should be high mlg
now while analyzing data data scientists
often need to create extra columns in
the data frame
to add more values that will help you
make your data analysis more efficient
so this question is related to one such
instance or one such
idea so here
you can see my data set
it has the brand name year kilometers
city and the mileage column now if
mileage is less than
25 i'll add the value low mlg
to my new column else if mileage is
greater than or equal to 25
i'll add high mlg to my new column so
here you can see
my final output wherever the mileage is
less than 25
it should print low mlg else it should
print
high mlg now let's do this on my jupyter
notebook
so we'll use lambda functions that we
learnt earlier to perform this task
i'll write a function let's say f is
equal to
you can call this as a function or a
variable
i'll give the keyword lambda
and use x as my
parameter now x
should be low mlg
if x
is less than 25 which is mileage here
else if it's not less than 25 it should
return
high mlg
now what i'll do is
i'll give my data frame scar
and i'll create my new column that is
mlg
then i'll write equal to
car dot i'll give my
column name from the original data frame
which is mileage
and i use my apply function and pass in
the variable
f now let's just
print this data frame
if i run it you can see the output here
we have created a new column which is
mlg
you can see our new column name was mlg
and these are the results so
for renault tata and kia for the last
three rows since the mileage is less
than 25 it returned
low mlg for the remaining it gave us
high mlg
now moving to the ninth question so this
is our next question
we want to create a 4 cross 4 matrix and
find the sum of all the diagonal
elements in the matrix
data scientists often work with multiple
dimensional arrays or multi-dimensional
arrays
and matrices to build models this
question is related to an operation on a
4 cross 4 matrix
so first we need to create an array
which
will be a numpy array of 4 cross 4
shape and then we'll see how to
calculate the diagonal elements
or the sum of the diagonal elements
so i am on my jupyter notebook first
let's import the numpy library so i'll
write
import numpy or numpy as np
let me run it okay now
i'll create my 4 cross 4 matrix so i'll
write
m is equal to
np dot array
and i'll create my 4 cross 4
matrix let's say the values are 1 2
3 4 in the first row and
in the second row i'll pass 5 comma 6
comma 7 comma 8.
in the third row we'll have 9 10
and 11.
also 12 and finally
we'll have 13 14
15 and 16
the fourth row i'll just run it
now if i print m you can see this is a
four cross four matrix
so this is one way of creating a four
cross four matrix which is a bit tedious
and lengthy
instead of that you can also use a range
function
so if i write m is equal to np dot
a range function and here i will give my
values starting from
1 till 17 so this will actually exclude
17 and
take from 1 to 16 and i'll
give my shape as 4 comma 4.
let me print it there you go
it has printed the exact same matrix
that we saw above
all right now to print the diagonal
elements we'll use the diagonal function
so i'll write print m dot
diagonal
let me just run it so 1
6 11 and 16 are my diagonal elements you
can see this matrix
1 6 11 and 16 are my diagonal elements
now to print the sum of all the diagonal
elements i'll use the sum function
so i'll write m dot diagonal
along with that i'll pass my sum
function
if i run it so the sum of 1
6 11 and 16 is 34.
okay so coming to the last question on
this interesting session on programming
interview questions for data scientists
our question is given a vehicle data
frame
find the average and maximum mileage of
the vehicles using pandas
so here data scientists use statistical
measures to analyze that data
so it is important to have knowledge of
the statistical functions in python
here is my vehicle data set and
for each brand of vehicle we want to
find the average and the maximum mileage
so let me show you how to do it
okay so here on the notepad i have my
code written
to create the vehicle data frame i'll
just copy it
and paste it on this cell
you can see we have the brand column the
year column
kilometers city mileage here you can see
the different
brand of vehicles let me just create
this data frame first
and let me go ahead and print the
vehicle data frame so i'll write vehicle
and
run it so here is the data frame
now i want to find the average and
maximum mileage for
each of the brands so for this
we'll use the group by function and the
aggregate function that is available in
the pandas library of
python so let me show you how to do it
i'll give a variable called
result and then i'll use my
data frame name as vehicle
followed by the group by function
i'll write group by and since i want to
check for all the brands so i'll group
all the
brand of vehicles then i'll use
an aggregate function which is egg
within curly braces i'll give my column
as
mileage i'll give a colon
and pass in mean which is for average
and i'll use max to find the maximum
mileage now let's
print it i'll write print
i'll give a message as the
average and maximum
mileage
of vehicles
let me just print the result
i'll run it
you can see it has resulted in an error
the reason is
in vehicle the v is capital
now if i run it there you go here you
can see on the
left we have the brand names we have
hyundai there's maruti and tata because
those were the only three brand of
vehicles we had
and for each brand you can see the mean
mileage and the maximum mileage for
maruti it was
26.33 and the maximum mileage is 28
similarly you can see for
tata vehicle as well so that brings us
to the end of this live session on
programming interview questions for data
scientists
i hope you liked it if you have any
queries then please put them in the chat
section or the comments section of the
video
also we'll be coming up with a live
session on sql interview questions for
data scientists soon
stay tuned for that thank you for
watching and keep learning
you